well there are two things one there's a
debate about what's happening to
religion in America our book is about
the world so it's possible for God to be
back generally and America to become BB
becoming marginally less religious I
mean I going from eighty-six percent to
seventy-six percent it is a bit of a
drop in terms of the number of people
who say that they're it belong to
specific Christian faiths in America
that's that's a drop but by any other
standard of country it's a it's a lot
and are put our book argues that if you
look at China you look at Asia you look
at Latin America and you evenly look at
Europe you see God coming back in most
places into personal lives but
everywhere into public lives and so the
two don't necessarily contradict each
other like that in terms of the numbers
inside America I think those are really
interesting if you most them we've gone
through if you look underneath the
headline numbers what seems to be
happening is a two-phase thing on the
one hand the people who were sort of not
particularly fervent believers or non
believers are definitely pushing towards
more towards atheism on the other side
the people who are believers tend to be
pushing more towards evangelicals to
Pentecostals towards conservative
versions of religion and so to some
extent you have a polarization between
those two and I think what's interesting
about that is that possibly it means
that religion those people imagine
religions going to disappear from
politics in America are in for a rude
shock because they've got both sides are
going to care much more and actually to
some extent what seems to be happening
in America is that the religious issue
used to be the sort of Republican issue
now it's becoming the Democrat issue as
well it's now about poverty the
environment all those things as well so
that in terms of the overall numbers
there might be a little judge or in
America it always goes in waves in
America I don't see any sign of America
becoming a non-religious country but the
underlying force of what's driving
American and religion along has always
been pluralism is being competition and
I actually see atheism as best part of
that competition
well I it's hard to say i think a
particular thing recently would seem to
be bush I mean Bush took a lot of people
who didn't really care that much about
religion and turn them into quite sort
of savage disbelievers you know people
people who suddenly confronted with the
idea of a theocracy confronted with the
idea of somebody who really wanted to
seem to put the church right in the
middle of American life that actually
persuaded I think quite a lot of people
that actually God was you know just get
him out of the system and you see that
in the reception of people like Dawkins
and Christopher Hitchens and people like
that but I think what's also interesting
about Dawkins and Kristen oceans is that
they are you know they're reacting to
something you don't you don't write a
book saying God is not great if you
think you've won the argument and what's
really interesting from a big global
perspective is I think for most of the
20th century the elite the global elite
have always has identified modernization
with secularization and America was seen
as an outlier a slightly strange thing
but in the end it would come in and
what's happening and very much what our
book is about is you look around the
world at the moment the more modern lots
of countries are becoming the more
religious they're getting go to I mean I
went to Turkey you go and see Ataturk
you know he totally believed in pulling
Islam out of the system now very much
you have the modern bourgeoisie who were
very much the people that wanted to
create they're the ones who actually
voting the AK Party go to India you see
exactly the same with the BJP some
modern people who narrow desperately
wanted to create airship Nerys grandson
now things are quite strong religious
things that it's exactly those people
are voting the BJP go to China the book
begins in China and a house church the
people in that house church were
absolutely the modern China there's stem
cell scientists their professors that
bankers their high tech executives and
for their meal angelica christianity is
almost a sort of way to get ahead in the
world that's very much the way in which
they see it as around the world whether
you notice this book is not a book
saying god is good or God is bad or we
exist so he doesn't it's an examination
of a phenomenon and the phenomenon is
that religion is back in the world is
back in politics it's back in public
life and that has good and bad
consequences in other country have good
things to do with people having choice
but we also detail lots of stuff like
Wars of Religion the way that culture
wars are going global but that is that
that basically is the world you have to
live with you either run away from that
or else you or else you can start
dealing with it
we actually align modernity with
pluralism I think that's the big
category mistake I'm Peter Berger who's
the Great's of sociologists of religion
you know who one time was a big
supporter of the secularization thesis
arguably the most sort of the biggest
proponent of it when he switched and
suddenly said lo actually pluralism is
the modern thing I think that's it and
that's what's the core of why we think
an American model loosely termed is
sweeping the world people are choosing
which religion to have they're doing the
same thing as Thomas Jefferson did you
know they're looking at the Bible and
cutting out the bits they feel like it's
like I want this and I'm on this and I'm
going to change this it's a much more
individual thing and the reason why that
is relevant to politics and public life
is if people are choosing their religion
rather than just inheriting it then that
means that when they go into the voting
booth they go into work even they're not
going to leave it at home in the same
way as they might have done before
it's the forces of progress of driving
it you look at globalization you look at
technology you look at the lot of
democracy you know if you're giving
these when you give people the vote
strangely a lot of religious people go
and vote for religious parties when you
give people technology strangely some
people who actually use it best are
often people like the mega churches
they're very very quick on to this if
you look at the way that that the
globalization spreads I think
globalization actually encourages the
demand for religion in two ways there's
one group of people who think we want
religion to be a sort of storm shelter
you can see the Koala that particular in
the Islamic world but you can focus if
they didn't rule arkansas rural india
you can see these people who think that
the world's out there it's a frightening
difficult place and religion is a form
of protection against it by contrast
what we also identified which i think is
the sort of unappreciated bit is that
for lots of people lots of up-and-coming
people visit the mega churches America
you don't see poor downtrodden people
there you see smart young suburb nights
they see this as a way to get ahead to
get ahead of other people very very true
in China very very true in career very
true in Latin America we see
Pentecostalism spreading very quickly
and the one exception is Europe which we
can to come back to which the harder
case to make this argument then all
other areas of the world for better or
worse in it that those things are being
allied and actually is going with a if
that's the sort of demand side that
there's a sub deeper demand side is
actually whether we like it or not man
seems to be a theater opik beast you
know given the option to believe in God
or some kind of afterlife or some kind
of meaning they will do so and if you
want the quintessential example of the
sort of modern religion it's your
president you know look at Barack Obama
there is a man whose life was that he
wasn't sure about it he found the
meaning in a Chicago church and what's
interesting about Obama i think is that
he is somebody who once you take him
onto the international stage we would
cheat able to see already on but once
you once you put that particular element
of faith on the international stage I
think you're going to see a very
different reaction to American religion
then you had with george w bush george w
bush typify
all the things that Europeans in
particular found suspicious and wrong
about American religion a team very hard
very intolerant it wasn't it wasn't the
same thing but I think a lot of
Europeans could identify with this
clever young well-educated man looking
for something more to life and discovery
in the church I thinks any accidents all
the best-selling religious book is
called the purpose driven life but
that's what that's the bit which is
striking a chord with globalization so
that's all the demand side that's why
people are going for it and you're the
one last thing on it there is now quite
a lot of science again the better or
worse which shows that religious people
are wealthier healthier and happier with
non-religious people so to that extent
it quote unquote works and you know
Dawkins is very interesting on that the
other thing which is driving religion if
that's the demand side is supply and you
have the spread of american-style
competitive religion where you are you
know you make great efforts to make
religion much easier you make church is
more comfortable you use every form of
modern technology embedded into people's
lives and you see that spreading into
other religions like Hinduism Buddhism
Islam as well and you see it spreading
around the world
that's a very good
and that that is the area where gold is
back is the hardest argument to prove
that said I think on one side it's clear
that the extent there are two parts of
this but one is saying here is the
politics they're going to be involving
religion and then there's also the basic
facts of people perhaps becoming more
religious generally that the on the
first bit that works completely with
Europe I think political Europe is
suddenly got religion back into the
public square in a way that people I
thought just assume they banished it
that's partly because of the arrival of
Islam in a big way suddenly you know
it's a big big part of domestic politics
in a variety of European countries
Sharia headscarves where exactly
reliable team mosque and state should be
what children should be taught what the
religious schools are a good idea a bad
idea these are all issues which are
suddenly floating back to the center you
also see it I think a degree amongst the
leaders you have Blair who famously said
we don't do God or other he spoke sment
did you know Blair is now running a
faith and politics Institute you have
golden brown again sort of quite a
religious perfect Sarkozy wrote a book
about it see the influence of all the
the East European countries so within
the political world I have no doubt that
the same kind of culture wars and stuff
which had been part of the American
world are going to be part of the
European world in a different way but
but certainly in a way that Europeans
just never imagined possible whenever
they looked at American politics they've
always it's always been a bit where they
thought that's an abomination it's not
going to come here but when it is so
politics yes you know God is very much
back in European politics the difficult
bit is God is back in terms of personal
religiosity there I think the evidence
is there's much more mixed on the one
hand Church attenders generally in most
places or the mainline churches are
still going down against AI I think you
could argue that on the on the edge it
is things are beginning to happen you
can see pentecostalism Greg very fast
and France you can see if you get to the
east end of london is a multitude of
different religions competing two
million britons have been through
something called the Alpha course which
is a sort of I'm kind of simplified
massively but a bit like the verse
The Purpose Driven Life in others desert
there's that there's a degree of change
there which just shows things are going
adult confirmations as it other change
childhood confirmations going down adult
ones I people older suddenly deciding I
want to commit myself to the Anglican
Church whatever those are actually going
up I my guess is over time the same sort
of forces which have been at work in
America as the European religious market
get sort of free air and easier and more
competitive they will work ie that if
you are a suburbanite in Bordeaux or
Birmingham England you will have some of
the same kind of reasons to drift
towards religion the same sub search for
meaning the same some cases same group
sports storm shelter all those things
will combine in the same way as they do
in Birmingham Alabama or wherever that
that's it says there's too much
similarity there for it not to swing
back a bit but no we're not predicting
that you know we're going to reach a
stage or what certainly at any time soon
where seventy-six percent of Europeans
immediately identified themselves as
christian
I think there is an element of truth in
that which the mega preachers doubt that
we call the pastor preneur they don't
they don't particularly like that aspect
but it has to be said and you know Rick
Warren's are very good so test case of
this is actually if you look at some of
the messages they're delivering amongst
this sort of cuddly a nicer thing you
know there's still quite hard line on
issues like abortion gay marriage
famously I mean Warren got into trouble
with a lot of people but you prior to
his his he's a gig at the Obama
inauguration you know that that I think
you know that was a maybe the surprise
some people around him that he was
suddenly seen as more intolerant quite
on quite funny person and people
imagined in the end a lot of them if you
listen what they actually teach this is
not quite far and brimstone but you know
it's got a quite stern message
underneath it so I think there is that
militating against it
we think that china will be the world's
biggest Christian country relatively
quickly and we think it'll probably also
be the world's biggest Muslim country
and maybe a bit later because Islam is
also growing particularly in the rural
West what I think's really interesting
about China is as I said is it's that
it's the it's the up-and-coming people
who are joining it there is a stud
secret a slight religious split the
Catholics in general are doing better in
the countryside it's the evangelical
more so American style stuff which is
particularly bordered by Koreans but
also by Americans and also by the
Chinese themselves that's what's really
moving in the cities and what is
interesting to me because again you know
book is an attempt to study this
phenomenon take people inside these
house churches show what they're like
but then ask the political questions
that flow from that and the readings you
get from the regime a very contradictory
illness on the one hand it says the
regime is prepared to encourage these
things huge in towers set really quite
nice things about religion even about
Christianity and there's there's some
element of suddenly Confucianism the
regime is quite comfortable with because
that they're looking in a sense for glue
to bring this huge country together
there is the level of social dislocation
in China is gigantic as one year I think
it's 1998 and I may have put it wrong
where the number of people moving from
the countryside to the towns in just
that one year is greater the number of
all the people who left Europe and came
to America in the hundred years before
nineteen twenty so you have social
dislocation or gigantic level and the
regime are aware of that that currently
having to deal with lots of economic
problems and they see religion at least
as a potential piece of glue to hold
that society together that's the sort of
good side on the other side they are
inherently worried and suspicious about
religion as a certain century force
there is people have told me that the
figure who the regime particularly
identifies is John Paul the second they
think John Paul the second they give him
an perhaps a a to greater role in the
Soviet Union's downfall but they see
parallels there there's a also famous
Chinese robe
in the 19th century which was led by
Christian you see all the evidence the
Falun Gong all those things make them
uneasy and what's happening with the
house churches as they get bigger
they're already arguably the biggest NGO
in China as they get bigger they're
starting to add things like some
nurseries and all those things the one
other absolutely brilliant thing about
what's happening in China which is sort
of Berlin is fascinating is what the
regime have been doing is the rules
within China basically saying the rules
of complicated but they sort of say when
you get to 25 people no meeting can go
beyond 25 people without government
approval well you have 25 people in a
house church once it gets to 27 28 the
church because of that rule is forced to
split and because it's also split it
grows so immediately you get two groups
of 12 who are out there looking for more
people so ironically the very rules the
Chinese have introduced turn out to be
the very things that make you some
religion grow quite as fast as it does
and that I think is a big thing
Islam is a difficult issue on the one
hand you have you know that the big
question about Islam is is will it have
some version and they hate this word of
the Reformation or enlightenment or some
sums of subversion that and the kind of
negative answer on that is it's
extremely difficult because if you look
at the number of genuine kind of real
reformers within Islam that sort of all
those sort of people who Westerners
rightly or wrongly might think of was
reformed as the sort of people might
allow women to say much more during
services all that type of stuff that's a
tiny tiny portion of the whole and the
main argument is but you know the
reformed tradition with Islam is
actually arguing that you should look at
things 300 years after the profit rather
than at the prophets time it's all it's
all based around quite elderly arguments
and there's an additional structural
reasons while Islam might find it
difficult to move one is that if you
look at the Quran the Quran is the
literal word of God you know it is not
like the Bible which essentially is
reportage if you can you know to base it
in that way the Bible is a collection of
stories about something people
describing what happened it's easier
much easier to reinterpret the Bible
than it is to change the corral the
Quran you know most Muslims insist it
has to be in Arabic because this is
actually what he said and it's much more
difficult for religion to find ways in
which to adapt to modernity that way but
secondly also on top of that they have
the problem of who they were Jesus
Christ was a sort of form of social
social difficulty he was causing he was
an outcast a bit over somebody said
described in the other day as I said of
am a community organizer which are of
life you know he was causing trouble
Muhammad by contrast was a prophet was
it was it was it was a rule giver he was
he was handing out laws about how you
live again that makes it harder to
change so for all those reasons Islam is
harder to change against that you know
look look around the world you bits of
the book we look at America is an area
where you have a large amount of Muslims
living actually very successfully in
Europe again you have people entering a
pluralistic society and again doing
pretty well you have the experiments now
a turkey and actually particular
indonesia i think is really interesting
all those areas
strike me as air is where Muslims will
come back to the center and say look we
need to we need to be more tolerant at
least of other religions I mean if you
if you have if you have a system whereby
anyone who converts away from Islam is
immediately under you know some cases
under really severe punishment that they
live but that that's really the acid
test of the modernity of a religion is
how tolerant is it about people being
able to choose what they want and that
that is that that's the bit which is
love finds particularly difficult but
within the main heartlands there isn't
much night of change but I I would be
quite optimistic actually about what in
the end will come out of European Islam
and actually particularly what will come
out of American Islam and if you want a
parallel there is actually one is that
the Second Vatican Council was actually
pushed particularly by an American
Catholic who put across edit you know
this this is we've got to face up to
what's happening around the world and he
went back to Rome and persuaded then
Pope to do it and that that that's you
know that there isn't there is some
degree of unprecedent but i'm not you
know nobody should expect this to happen
immediately
I think the most where think there's two
bits I think from the point of view of
where is sort of faith taking off I
think China is fascinating I think from
the point of view of where is it
dangerous know where do you actually see
the repercussions of this beginning
perhaps to cause real trouble I I would
give the example of Africa where it were
to be very crude a basic about it you
have fundamentalist Islam pushing down
and you have evangelical Christianity
pushing up and in the book I went to the
front line in Nigeria between these two
terms of car new and Joss it is that you
drive along it and that you will find
mosques los church church and they
battling almost all the way and sadly in
many cases actually you know it does
spill over into violence 20,000 30,000
people have been killed I think in the
last 20 years there and and to have
these epic battles is quite normal and
it does have some degree of tribe tribal
nurse underneath the difficulty of
religion is once it gets into a dispute
it makes it much much harder to solve a
classic example being the the middle
east in the holy land when the
israeli-palestinian thing was primarily
a secular affair which it certainly was
to begin with you know then it's easier
to say look here's the border where
divide it you know most people sort of
know what the eventual solution is or
should be but actually you it's much
much harder to do it if both sides claim
that God gave them the whole thing is
once once it involves fundamental truth
as perceived and you see it a bit with
the life debate here or no no like
stroke abortion debate it's the same
thing you cannot compromise you cannot
give way I think the answer is you
possibly can give away a bit more than
people have done you can see how Matt's
already talking about this idea of of
course the land would always be Islam
but they prepared to let israel occupied
on a sort of temporary release of
participants which is a bizarre way of
looking at it with the underneath it
there is a struggle repeated struggle
between you know religious people if
what's religion gets back into politics
that makes a huge difference and in many
ways but we're living through I think in
terms of the world as we see it is
America has got one
I ganteng right he's got the basic
division of church and state which both
encourages religion and on the other
hand provides a way in which religion
can foster within a political system the
bit which the Americans didn't get right
was foreign policy whereas the Europeans
I think to be fed them were always much
more scared about what was happening
within religion Americans just simply
weren't they didn't want to think and
this goes right the way through to bush
as well Bush ibly I mean it goes back
earlier you look back at Iran when the
Iranian Revolution was was was in
preparation somebody at the CIA produced
a report saying look actually that
there's a lot of religion this
immediately dismissed as mere sociology
which is about as rude as you can get
inside the CIA when his brother emerged
again the American political
establishment to try to save in terms of
left and right and where it worked with
the Russians and so on its name is the
party of god that was there was a basic
refusal to see this as part of the
argument and actually even going through
bush despite all that sort of God
bothering aspect of Bush Iraq it took
them a long time to understand the
sunni-shia split that that was
absolutely crucial and again and again
and again you find these examples of
people I think American foreign policy
exception is still very secular in that
respect and now it's beginning to learn
and why is that important because you
never ever get solutions without
bringing the sort of people of faith
into it if you want it the one example
where people have done that is Northern
Ireland people went out and they bought
in people from both sides you had
priests Catholic fries Protestant
rector's sitting down each time there's
an atrocity both sides you know they
stood together and they condemned both
sides if there was a moment of proj neri
it was condemned as well as in the
Catholic area transpose the
israeli-palestinian dispute you just I
mean it happens occasionally but
virtually never it's not like each time
a rocket lands on a Palestinian house a
lot of people are killed you do not see
a rabbi an imam standing together saying
this is you know this is deplorable nor
do see when a suicide bomber goes the
other way and that that of month until
you get that
it's going to be very very difficult for
us of lasting peace to come through
Benedict is an interesting figure to the
extent that he seems to be interested in
the idea of a kind of smaller more
vibrant perhaps abused word more
hardcore church that seems to be seems
to be what he's aiming for and there's a
concept which people use sometimes in
talking about the european union of a
two-speed union where you have an
internal bit of you know the within the
European Union it be the French the
Germans the Belgians all caught up in it
pushing together total integration and
then you would have a second speed of
people like the British issue who sort
of like bits of the European Union but
not the whole thing and that should you
imply that to Catholicism and I know
it's something of a stretch from one to
the other I think that's pretty much for
Benedict serious be aiming for he he
definitely wants a sort of more
evangelical charismatic and quite tough
minded Catholicism at the center and
then he wants a variety of them the LOB
sort of fellow travelers around the
outside but they either he's focus is
going to be on that little bit I think
and you could argue that the I mean in
the book we don't make judgments within
the Economist we do you know could all
give her stuff he said about
contraception in Africa totally sort of
fits that
I think the two bits of that I think
religion well firstly religion was doing
pretty well before this crisis so you
could argue you know maybe it's going to
unseat it a bit I suspect probably not I
think I think actually particularly
perhaps in America that element of
suddenly kind of personal crisis people
losing their jobs people being scared
that will I think probably drive people
back to back to churches a bit as i said
you know these things come in waves and
i suspicion is that one sort of big
evangelical wave may just be cresting a
bit I don't know whether the economy in
some ways will give it a little bit more
legs the other day I went to saddleback
church which is a Rick Warren's one and
he was that there was an event which
they expected a thought a couple of
hundred people to come to come to
instead of which a couple of thousand
did and I suspect there might be some
element we don't know of depression
economics that work there you know it
said that people say that recessions are
good for movie theaters and churches
that could yet be true in terms of
religions role in causing the economic
economic crash I don't think even i can
even even even like all authors i'm
always desperate to tie things into my
subject matter but i think i can't quite
do that
there is a big argument which i think is
very relevant to the modern sort of
political situation which goes something
like this when people look at forces
like globalization and economics that
there has been a a presumption
particularly amongst the business
community that the world of the past 100
years that the bait that was a person
world of the past 25 years the basic
push of globalization because it's got
technology and it's got economic logic
behind it because it is you know billion
people have been dragged out of poverty
by this thing it this will continue and
yet and yet you know there are less
rational things that work and religion
original I think is one of those that's
but that's where it fits into me it fits
in the sense that people will not in
India at the moment in has got an
election coming up there is salvation on
the economy but they will also vote on
issues about how exactly you treat is
long how exactly you deal with that
there are a lot of irrational things at
work with in politics and that's what
makes it very difficult for people who
are purely technocratic particularly the
business community there is this there
is this presumption that if you have
economic logic and technology on your
side or appear to that in the end
everything is going to be okay and yes
that's what my suspicion is yes it will
be okay but you know that's my sort of
sixty percent bet so to speak but I
think there is another there's a sort of
thirty percent chance actually something
stupid political emotional perhaps
including some true religion will
intervene you know there are strange
forces out there at the moment if you
want a particularly you know again I'm
not predicting this is the same look
back at a lot of the literature with all
the First World War you know people then
just assume that even if there was a war
which most people totally assume there
wouldn't be that it wouldn't really
affect the this fantastic period of
prosperity they'd had before and in fact
actually there then tumbled through out
of the war and to eventually until you
got the twenties but then you had the
horrors of the depression you know that
it's it's very rational things there
Peter Peter Drucker the management think
it had a very nice line one search
you know whenever to economic lodge
logic has confronted I think it's
politics and nationalism it hasn't
always been the format that's one and I
again I think that's the it's those in
those cracks where things appear in and
what happens if Iran in America at the
moment that that there is a logical sort
of compromise to make if you're the
mullahs in Iran you know that you've
gained a lot you know partly because of
GW Bush you you you have got a lot more
power what would you do with it you cash
in your chips that with a rational thing
to do but how rational are they
I think it's highly unlikely in the
short term that the Democrats will
become the party of evangelical
Christianity I think it is quite likely
in the longer term that they will the
facts already happened what's what's
changed if you look back at the
difference between john kerry and then
barack obama and the sort of people
around him you had both barack obama and
hillary clinton very much running trying
to bring in quote unquote people of
faith talking about their own religious
experiences in a way that previous
democrats haven't there was a desperate
effort to bring it in and as I think you
indicated there right there are these
issues there's kind of creation care as
they call the environment there's
there's development poverty around the
world you know that's an area where
actually there's a lot of similarity I
think between the sort of likes of Obama
and write more or less you know they're
both looking at all these things and I
think there's there's two bits going on
on the on the religious right that sort
of birth of what some people call the
new new right which is you know much
many ways a much more modern still quite
hard still very hard line on abortion
still pretty hard line on gay marriage
but certainly has no wish to be seen as
intolerant either take a young
evangelicals you get that very very
strongly they even if they don't agree
with great marriage they get out of
their way to say they have gay friends
at all these base on you notes of the
way the people from some kinds
intolerant people try to explain things
but it is that you know it's it's very
much along those lines on within the
Democratic side I just think the levels
to which you know you had Howard Dean
running in I think 2002-2004 who put the
book of Job in the in the New Testament
that were there were there what people
were Democrats used to be completely
utterly kind of a Krista phobic I
suppose over to either way did not
obviously you know Clinton nothing was
quite a religious man but they didn't
they didn't they didn't try to emanate
that I think now I know bomber very
strongly did and that i think you know
you need to do that given the fact that
most americans for better or worse a
religious you need to give the
impression that their values are
somewhat closer to yours and there are a
lot of issues like poverty like the
environment were absolutely the
Democrats are speaking
to that
you very unwise to take investment
advice for me saying I was the man who
invested in Euro tunnel which is it
happened to go through the channel dong
to get built but this alley investors
didn't make money I think in general
terms the way in which the economy is
probably again to recover is going to be
through sort of solid structural
industries you know things with things
would think things which people really
need that's pretty much always what
happens when when economies come back
you've seen that this time is that
you've seen at some level whereby things
like consumer goods and stuff like that
people if people still want to buy and
don't see it as ridiculously expensive
to buy coca-cola or washing better or
ball all those type of things if I had
to look for a kind of particular bit
which I would imagine really coming back
I would focus actually on that that that
sector which I alluded to a bit earlier
you know that there is a billion people
who've been dragged out of absolute
poverty into something which is a sort
of middle-class life maybe not by
American standards but certainly by the
standards of India China Brazil all
those places and that those those the
people who are just beginning to start
to buy stuff you know that they're they
they're the ones you're buying scooters
if not perhaps cars maybe maybe the
Tartan Arno's the first nana's of you
know the one which is going to bring
people in but on the whole these these
are people who you know they're trying
to invest in their children's education
they're trying to spend money on their
on stuff on clothes on food of more than
just a subsistence level they're
actually trying to invest in what
they're doing and that I think is a
broad class of people which if companies
who are aiming at them have can do
extremely well
I think the thing about globalization is
its unevenness it's not a its people
always assume it's a fact it's not as
again as I said earlier you know people
business people who assume globalization
is just there and its net is never going
to go away should go and read history
books very quickly because it the
answers it can get reversed in the end
globalization relies on political
decisions it relies on tariffs being
down it relies on people being in goods
being able to cross borders and just to
give you a sort of frightening example
what happens if there is a dirty nuclear
bomb in Delhi or and there was Manhattan
you know what would that do to shipping
stuff around the world people be far
more paranoid it's those sort of things
which could could get unstable it that
the underlying bits of globalization I
mean the which I think you have to look
at it as broadly as possible i see
globalization as you know ever freer
movement of goods capital people but
also ideas around the world and that is
generally why you know we are we are
hoping a great liberal newspaper that is
why we've always been sort of Foursquare
behind it and for us it so you know
economic freedom and individual freedom
it absolutely go together but they come
from the same source
I think they're well there are lots of
downsides of the sense of individual
people who get caught out by this kind
of often accrual process I'm a
particular group of people who have
always been vulnerable have tended to be
the workers in richer countries who are
more vulnerable to foreign competition
you shouldn't push that too hard I mean
if you look at most most things there's
been a lot of the big arguments recently
about wages in America you know why of
wages in America kept down and
globalization is usually figured as the
culprit and that's in ms the evidence is
no it's not the real thing which has
kept wages down is technology and the
problem is that it's very hard for a
politician to blame computers for
people's jobs going or for pressure on
wages it's much easier to say it's the
Chinese or the Indians but again you
know look just just think through your
your life you need to think that the
difference between banks when there were
lots of tellers and now the fact you
have atms to go and get stuff for that
they had a colossal effect on industry
far greater than saying after which i
remember was sort of going through it
roughly the same time that nafta
attracted all the headlines and that's
that's the problem with globalization
that the basic economic logic of it is
always disturbed by the politics of how
it's how it's pushed forward
can also be used to snoop on you to tell
say where you're going to collect your
records to decide even I'm good you know
difficult things of technology or all
this stuff again going back to some of
the religion arguments to do with
cloning to do with what you knowing
individual things about which jeans you
have on how you act upon them in that
that's going to be both liberating and
also in some cases possibly frightening
and even in us on a Machiavellian way
could be frightening so all that's going
to go on I mean the whole technology
poses problems but there is never a
bigger property near the worst thing is
always to try and oppose it you know on
the whole technology should be let to
push ahead it tells us tough I'm excited
about that moment I mean one particular
thing which applies to our industry if
you want to look at the newspapers and
magazines and I forgive me for the
selfish aspect to it is I think the
whole aspect about how how people will
be reading and looking in these papers
and magazines in the future i think is
very interesting you have devices like
the kindle you know what exactly
difference that will make and technology
doesn't it has a way of coming along
when either solving problems or
complicating them in a dramatic way that
there are huge things to do with health
care as well going on which i think a
fascinating weather but it's much better
i think the technology just to accept
it's coming even if you're personally
somewhat technologically inept like i am
you know these this stuff eventually
comes through and make them and changes
the world
people want to get in
mation quickly they're much more likely
to get it by quickly logging on and
foremost case not you have to log on
just it just appears in front of them
magazine so far have been immune to
their relatively immune to that because
people people people read magazines
sitting back you know they're more
relaxed and the question is whether the
next generation of PDAs and things like
that will be good enough to replicate
that experience will we end up having a
sort of version of a kindle or say the
reader which which which is sort of
foldable or we know could fit in your
pocket I don't know that those I think
you know it's a good example of how
technology could come a lot one lot of
technology comes along and disrupts and
industry another load of technology
comes along and perhaps changes it for
the better
true you can have you can have fun we
have a long special report coming out an
economist all about healthcare and
technology where you you in a few years
and it features one gentleman whose name
I'm I can't remember but I think he's
now ninety had 40 years ago he was
talking about how the way in which
technology should completely transform
healthcare and look where we got to you
know you go to your doctor most doctors
still write down your your information
or a piece of paper each time you go to
a new doctor you have to re-enter the
whole thing patient power is going to
grow that there should be a pretty
dramatic change I think in terms of you
know when people have illnesses they can
they're beginning all ready to go to
particular websites and picking up
particular information that you ready
you're seeing signs of people we need to
mark doctors saying how good are there
this how good a day at that and I think
beyond that there's this give me the
simple element of just having a lot of
information about you out there which
causes some degree some degree of them
privacy concerns but on the other hand
makes life gigantically easier if you if
everyone had a card on them which gave
95 presentable they're available medical
information that would actually make a
dramatic difference in anything sleigh
accidents and all that type of stuff
because all the tests people now have to
run pretty routinely you wouldn't need
and also on top of that you're going to
get all the cross-disciplinary stuff
look at a research into cancer a lot of
the stuff to do with cancer the new
thing which they're looking at cancer
involves stem cells actually what was
interesting was that the the big
possibly big breakthrough in cancer came
not from people who are spending their
entire time studying cancer but actually
from people who were looking something
slightly different and so I think this
cross-disciplinary aspect of people
suddenly being able to jump from bit to
bid I think is very interesting and a
particular thing which says worries me a
bit it's the degree of specialization we
we increasingly have in the world you
know people people taking on the
academic side people tend to focus on
their their narrower thing you know it's
no longer you know not an English
literature professor you are Jane
Austen's latest two novels professor if
that's what you specialize in and some
of that breath that there's an
interesting contradiction to my mind at
least looking for the outside between
the bra
this is often why the bigger ideas that
we found and yet the narrow
specialization you could argue back to
Adam Smith the people of people being
forced to go into and it's the tension
between those two things which i think
is fascinating
the basic so I thinking don't always
changes about things but in terms of the
basic idea that book was called the
company a short history of a
revolutionary idea and the basic idea
behind it was that actually the this
boring institution the company the joint
stock company actually was a
revolutionary technology it took an idea
about a way to run businesses that way
to be able to bring in outside capital
and above all the idea of limited
liability and that actually completely
transformed the world if you he was an
example getting back to what we
originally said you know when the joint
stock company I'm a first appeared back
in I think Elizabethan England and then
helped many ways colonize America at
that precise time you would argue that
the Islamic world had much much more
advanced commercial structures than the
European anglo-european world did what
happened in fact is that the Islam got
left behind and one big reason for that
was they were unable to come up with the
structure partly to do with actually
reasons to do with religion and
inheritance and stuff like that which
could actually deal with joint stock
companies that make it that made a big
difference I think the company is still
an amazing organization watch what comes
out of the current crisis about it is
harder and we could argue that to some
extent when you looked at banks the
concept of limited liability hasn't gone
remedies it has been very limited
liability for the people at the top of
them that the full way in which
capitalism was supposed to work whereby
people who you did very well will then
supposed to lose a huge amount when they
went is true people that top of banks
have have lost quite a lot of money but
there's still a general feeling out
there that that people have got a lot
for nothing and what triggs me on that
is a particular thing to do with the
company we know we argue is a
revolutionary organization but it's
always relied on some degree of a
franchise from society whenever
companies whenever corporate capitalism
is seen to go too far in some direction
or another there's usually not always
for the better but there's always been
some degree of backlash has always been
some degree of that we want this mag and
it is worth remembering at unit
companies exist because of the state
they exist because
the state decides to give uniquely to
accompany the concept of of limited
liability if you get Buster I gave us
then that's new that's asked personally
that a company has that ability just to
keep all its debts within itself and the
people behind it not to be not to be hit
for the foot for the full bill and that
that is a you know that that is a
privilege given by the state and
although in general I'm much more
frightened about there being far too
much regulation after the particular
this particular episode we're still
getting through it that there's there's
a reason at least conceptually to
imagine why people might want to
re-examine that that relationship
I think I think what Brown is really
interested by at the moment is the
global institutions that's what that's
what he you talk to brown he will argue
obvious to me that you know the
Economist great argument in great great
paper of constitutional reform look at
the global institutions and try and work
out what you know what what you should
do with them and I think there is you
know he's on to something in one way but
there is an inherent tension in it is
that when you look at these
organizations like the IMF and the World
Bank and so on there is an element
whereby there's an immediate lack of
Kong court between the two on the one
hand you of global capitalism on the
other hand you have much less impressive
global institutions and then you have
this global crisis and people
immediately say well we want to have a
bigger you know a much more dramatic
superstructure to rule the entire thing
you could see that at the g20 meeting
where they bolstered the IMF which I
thought was a a very good idea
particularly for the emerging world but
fundamentally in terms of there being a
global regulatory answer to this crisis
I just don't think that works and the
reason really is to do with America is
that this crisis began in America it was
that was a absolutely epicenter so if
you have any dreams of a global
regulator running the world you would
have to imagine a system whereby the
global regulator will be bossing around
the Treasury bossing around and that's
just not going to happen so to some
extent there's a it's a it's an idea
which theoretically has some degree of
attraction but actually once you get hit
the practice of it is very difficult
partly because you just hit realpolitik
I cannot see any American president
agreeing to have the IMF telling him
what to do or telling her
you